hello someone I'm Samuel Lee's I'm a
property investor and I'll make a lot of
money in property and I also like to
share my opinions on investing in
property now listen this is a disclaimer
I'm gonna be talking about interest
rates right now I'm not a financial
adviser I'm only going to be giving my
opinion now I'm going to be keeping this
pretty simple and pretty basic as in in
other words what this means to you the
investor so interest rates base rate
dropped to 0.1 percent now you might be
thinking but what does that mean how
does that affect me like what's the big
deal all right interest rates drop to
zero point one percent I say this it is
a big deal and it does affect you
interest rates being 0.1% is lower than
it's been for hundreds of years interest
rates have not been as low as 0.1
percent since 1694 that's the 1600
that's insane so what is base rate being
0.1% even mean what that means is
commercial banks can borrow money from
the central bank's ie the Bank of
England for 0.1 percent so their
component extremely cheap how does that
affect you that means that you can also
borrow money extremely cheap that means
you can get mortgages extremely cheap
you can get a buy select mortgage right
now for like two three percent as I say
guys I'm just someone that makes money
in property but being able to get money
at two three percent interest and then
invest that into a property that's big
that's just insane in the 80s it was
base rate was 15 percent mortgages will
extremely high so if you want to borrow
money to buy a property you have to make
really high interest right now in 2020
that isn't the case right now it's
really really really cheap if you can't
make money in property if you can't make
more than two or three percent you
frankly just don't know I just don't
know how to invest in property at all
so what I'm thinking is if the banks are
giving that much money at that cheap and
base rate zero point one percent
and I can borrow that money and I can
invest in property and I can then make
20 30 % I'd be just insane not to and
you know what we're going to look back
in history at 20/20 and it's going to be
like remember how easy was to borrow
money
remember how cheap it was to borrow
money remember how much money the banks
were giving to normal people Joe Bloggs
property investor to build their
property portfolio like wasn't it easy
wasn't it easy now if you're a skeptic
you'll be thinking yeah but if I am Joe
Bloggs the normal invest them and I
borrow money and buy property what's
going to happen is interest rates are
going to go up really high you know it's
a couple of years and then I'm gonna be
stuck with the load but the thing is you
can fix interest rates you can borrow
money and you can fix the interest rate
it's not variable it doesn't have to be
variable which means that you can fix it
for like five years some lenders are
late and you fix interest rates for up
to 10 years what's going to happen in 10
years is that rents are going to go up
what's going to happen in 10 years is
that you've been up you're going to
built a large property portfolio and
become rich so I just wanted to put this
message out there to say now is a crazy
time massive opportunity interest rates
as low as they've been and also interest
rates being low I hear these people
saying why don't we save up money and
put it in the bank you don't want to do
that because the bank are giving such a
pathetic return on investment it's
embarrassing
instead of you giving money to the bank
and then the bank giving you a pathetic
return on investment and then investing
it themselves you right now in my
opinion should be getting money from the
bank and growing your portfolio becoming
rich leveraging their money so that's
the opportunity and listen you can you
take take on my guidance and say I'm
going to do this and you can get wealthy
or you can say I'm not sure I'm not sure
I'm not sure but if you do the latter
what's going to happen is in 10 20 years
your kids are gonna stay your grandkids
are gonna say what were you thinking is
it true that in 2020 you could base
rates with 0.1% and you're gonna be like
is it true that you could get money from
the banks and build your property
portfolio and you can fix interest rates
yeah it's true
in 2020 Samuel lead who's givin out free
YouTube videos teaching you how to
invest in property yeah it's true then
what were you thinking you know what
were you thinking and you'll have
nothing to give them apart from an
excuse and a sad story figure out how to
capitalize on the situation and go and
get rich and if you want help from me
I'm here I'm happy to help
I've done it myself I've been investing
now for over ten years
and I literally teach everything I'm
doing and teach everything I know
Google questions pick my brain if you
want more information on what to do
subscribe right here and if you want to
see what house prices are going to do
check it out right here my opinion is
what's going to happen with the pop
house prices but don't forget subscribe
I'll see you next time